So that was opening.
You erode, and then you dilate.
Well, some of us come from
the other side of the tracks.
We like to dilate, and then erode.
Same thing was eh, again using
the same structuring element.
So, using the same words from before,
you can show that closing of A by B,
all right?
Is, it says it's the complement of
the union of all translations of B
that don't overlap A, well that's
much better shown in a picture.
Right?
So now we take our paintbrush B and
we run it on the outside of A,
where we're not allowed to go touch,
go inside of, of that and
what results is the new area that
is that, that, that's been painted.
And one of the things that's
interesting to see is,
you see how this notch is smoothed out.
But because of the convexity of this and
the ve, I can actually move
this around very precisely,
right around that, so this is,
these external corners are preserved.
Okay, so it, it,
it fills up sort of concave corners, but
it, it remains,
it keeps convex ones there.
So, again,
if I run that brush over and over and
over again, I'm going to get the same
painting that I got before, and
again it's idempotent or
idempotent, pick your favorite.
Okay?
The repeated operation has no effect.
So, here's an example of doing closing.
Take an image,
threshold it, close it, and
you get, but you might say it's a pretty
reasonable outline of the boundary.
You notice,
it did catch some of the shadow
well that's because your threshold
pulled up some of the shadow.
So again, you know,
it's effective in a variety of ways
of sort of cleaning things up.
It's not like that it give you
sort of perfect image processing.